(loud whoosh)
- What's up, Believe Nation?
I started the Mentor
Me series with the goal
to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us
and leverage some of their skills,
their knowledge, their ideas,
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today, we're going to
learn from Mark Zuckerberg
on his Facebook story.
Mentor me, Mark.
And as always, guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you see something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and if you write it down,
it's much more likely
to stick with yourself as well.
(orchestral music)
- I built the first version of Facebook
because it's something
that my friends and I
wanted to use at Harvard, a
directory and a way to connect
with the other people around us.
I didn't think at all that
it was going to be a company.
I remember very specifically
the night that we launched
the first version.
I went out to get pizza
with a couple of my friends
who now work here.
I remember really clearly
we were talking about
how one day, we thought that
someone was going to build
a community like this for the world,
and that that would be some company,
but it clearly wasn't going to be us.
It wasn't even--
- It didn't even occur.
- Yeah.
It wasn't even an option
that we considered
that it might be us.
We just weren't focused on
building a company back then.
We were just building something
that we thought would
be useful at our school.
With Facebook, there was
just such, people loved it,
and had such an intensity of using it.
I think within a couple of weeks,
two thirds of students
at Harvard were using it,
and all these other students at MIT
and other local universities
were writing in,
asking us if we could open
up Facebook at their school.
So we kind of just followed that.
Again, I didn't set out and
my roommates didn't set out
to build a service that we were
going to turn into a company,
but we just followed what people wanted,
and that led us to expand it
to all these other schools
and eventually beyond schools.
At some point, once we'd
hired a bunch of people,
we decided to turn it into a company
and go for this mission
of connecting the world,
but that's not where we started.
I think one of the hardest parts for me
was actually when Yahoo
offered to buy the company
for a lot of money, because
up until that point,
that was the turning point in the company
where before that,
every day we'd just come in
and do what we thought was
the right next thing to do.
We'd open to more schools.
We opened to high school
and opened beyond schools
and launched more photos,
'cause that's what seemed like
the next thing that we needed to do
to help people express themselves
and understand more what
was going on around them.
But then, Yahoo came in with
this really meaningful offer,
a billion dollars for--
- And this was how far into the company?
- It was a couple of years in.
We had 10 million people
using the product at the time,
so it wasn't as if it were obvious
that we were going to
succeed far beyond that,
and that was the first
point where we really
had to look at the future and say,
"Wow, is what we're going to build
"going to actually be so much
more meaningful for this?
That caused a lot of
interesting conversations
in the company and with our investors,
and at the end of that,
Dustin and I just decided,
"No, we think that we
can actually go connect
"more than just the 10 million
people who are in schools.
"We can go beyond that
"and have this really
be a successful thing."
And we decided to go for it,
but it was really stressful,
'cause a lot of people really thought
that we should sell the company.
For a lot of folks who joined a startup,
I feel like at that point
I hadn't been very good
about communicating that we were
trying to go for this mission.
We just showed up every day
and just did what we thought
was the right next thing to do.
So for a lot of the folks
who joined early on,
they weren't really aligned with me.
For them, they joined, and
being able to sell a company
for a billion dollars
after a couple years,
that was like a home run.
And it is a home run.
I get that, but I think that the fact that
I didn't communicate very well
about what we were trying to
do caused this huge tension.
And the part that was painful
wasn't turning down the offer.
It was the fact that after that,
huge amounts of the company quit
because they didn't believe
in what we were doing.
If you look at the
management team that we had--
- [Interviewer] Did that
whole management team leave?
- The whole management team.
It was gone within
about a year after that.
- Did you ever regret that
decision in that period?
Were there times where you were like,
"Well, we should've sold."
- I got really lucky,
because not only did what I
believed in end up working out,
but it ended up working
out pretty quickly.
So literally, I think this
was in the summer of 2006,
and by, I think the next month after that
we launched News Feed,
which now 10 years later,
looking back at it is one
of the most used products
in the world, and then we launched
the ability for anyone to sign up,
which immediately started
growing the community.
So within a few months after
turning down the offer,
I think it was actually pretty clear
that it was the right decision.
But I think since then, there have been
much harder to decisions
that we've had to make
where sometimes you
have to bet on something
and either bet the
direction of the company
or bet billions of dollars on something,
and it's not going to be
clear whether you're right
for five or 10 years, and
that, I think, actually,
can end up being much
harder than this one.
- That's what I want to talk about next,
but before we go there,
have you ever thought about
selling the company again since?
- No.
After that point--
- So that was just--
- Yeah.
- Got that out of the way.
We're going to hire people that
want to be here for a long time.
- Yeah.
I always think that you should start
with the problem that you're
trying to solve in the world
and not start with deciding that
you want to build a company.
I mean, the best companies that get built
are things that are trying to drive
some kind of social change,
even if it's just local in one place,
more than starting out
because you want to make a bunch of money
or have a lot of people working for you
or build some company in some way.
So I always think that this is
kind of a perverse thing
about Silicon Valley in a way,
which is that people decide often
that they want to start a company
before they even decide
what they want to do.
And that just feels
really backwards to me.
And for anyone who's had the experience
of actually building a company,
you know that you go through
some really hard things along the way,
and I think part of what
gets you through that
is believing in what you're doing
and knowing that what you're doing
is really delivering a
lot of value for people,
and that's, I think,
how the best companies
end up getting made.
- Actually, I spend a bunch of time
analyzing and reflecting on why it was
that we were even able to do it, because
all reasons suggest that
we shouldn't have been able to do it,
because all these other companies
had way more engineering power,
and servers and time and
money and all this stuff.
And I actually think that this
is a pretty instructive thing
for anything that you want to go do,
because the same property
is going to be true
for anything that you guys start,
is that someone else is
going to have more resources
and be able to do it.
The reason why I think we actually
ended up being the ones
doing it is because
we just cared way more
about it than everyone else.
So there were always projects
at some of these other companies
that were these hobbies,
but we always thought that it was
this really important thing
and really just felt in
our gut and our heart
that we wanted to do it.
Early on, there were always
these skeptics saying that,
"Oh, this can't be a business."
We didn't actually care that much
about it being a business early on.
But a lot of the reason
why bigger companies didn't invest in it
was because it wasn't clear
that there was a model
that would work for it.
- [Interviewer] It seemed like a bad idea.
- Yeah.
I actually think that that's true
for a lot of the best ideas,
where it is that it's not
that someone else can't do it.
They actually can, and the
odds are stacked against you,
but I think often that
belief and the fact that
you just care so much
about what you're doing
is the only thing that
drives you to do it.
And to be honest, that kind
of drives me to this day.
I mean, one of the big emphasis points
for the company right now is Internet.org,
and for a while we had
this rallying cry of,
"Can we connect a billion people?"
And when we started talking about that,
we thought that was crazy.
It was bigger than any
service in the world
that had been built, and
it was 10 digits long.
It just felt crazy.
We'd never get to that.
But then the thing is,
as we started to actually
get closer to that,
we took a step back, and we were like,
"All right, well our
mission isn't actually
"to get one in seven people
in the world to be connected.
"It's we want to connect everyone."
So it's a big issue that only around
a third of the people in the world
have access to the Internet,
and that's something that we think
that we can do something about.
And similar to early Facebook,
there's no business model around this.
All the people who have
all the money in the world,
it's not necessarily a fair thing,
are already the people
who are on Facebook,
it's in the first seventh of the world.
But we just believe really strongly.
It's like this is what we are here to do.
This is what our company cares about.
I care about it.
The team cares about it.
Our culture cares about it.
So we're just going to keep pushing on it.
And I actually think a lot of the reason
why great stuff gets built is because
it's kind of irrational
at the time, so it selects
for the people who care
the most about it doing it.
We had a very simple focus and idea.
The goal wasn't to make
a huge community site.
It was to make something
where you could type in someone's name
and find out a bunch of
information about them.
(synthesizer music)
So I took a few days and
just threw together Facebook
and launched it on February 4th, 2004.
It was just me working on it at that time,
but at that point, my roommate Dustin,
who hadn't had much computer
programming experience at all,
was like, "I can help you expand it,"
and I'm like, "That's cool, dude,
"but you don't know how
to program." (laughs)
So he's like, "No, no, it's not an issue."
He went home one weekend, bought
the book Perl for Dummies,
came back and was like,
"All right, I'm ready."
And then we started getting emails
from people at a bunch of other schools
asking if we could launch Facebooks there.
In the last tech bubble,
most websites were run
using these really expensive machines,
which made it that you had to
basically go and raise money
before you could do anything.
We ran the site originally
for 85 dollars a month,
renting computers for
the first three months.
- [Interviewer] Were you ever in debt?
- I was in debt 160 dollars. (laughs)
In a world that's changing so quickly,
the biggest risk you can
take is not taking any risk.
I really think that that's true.
A lot of people, I think, think that...
Whenever you get yourself into a position
where you have to make some big shift
in direction or do something,
people are going to point
to the downside risks of that decision.
Locally, they may be right.
For any given decision
that you're going to make,
there's upside and downside.
But in aggregate, if you are stagnant
and you don't make those changes,
then I think you're guaranteed
to fail and not catch up.
So to some degree, I
think it's really right
that over time the biggest
risk that you can take
is to not take any risks.
Now we've made a huge number
of mistakes along the way.
I always say, I just think we've made
probably every possible
mistake you could make.
- Is there a decision that you've made
that the people around
you told you was a mistake
and you defied them and you were right?
- The most famous one, I think,
probably has to do with
selling the company.
In 2006, we had this opportunity
to sell the company to
Yahoo for a billion dollars,
and we turned that down.
I think a lot of people at the time
thought that we should sell the company,
but I felt really strongly.
I think now people generally think that
that was a good decision.
A lot of people who I think
build startups or companies
think that selling the
company or going public
is this end point.
It's like you win when you go public.
That's just not how I see it.
- [Interviewer] What do you think
that Facebook brings to the table
that other online communities don't have?
- I think that the fact that Facebook
is tied into the real world
instead of just being an online community
is the big difference.
So a lot of online communities
don't really have a set culture,
so people don't know how to act online.
Right now, we're face to face
and we're acting in a certain way,
which is different than we'd act
if you were just a screen name
on my monitor or something.
The fact that this is tied to culture,
my friends at Harvard will
observe how I act on Facebook,
makes it a different kind of community,
because it's actually an online community
with the values of a real community.
So I think that makes it cool.
It makes it so that there's
real life, useful information
that's available there,
and the interactions
also sometimes are more
applicable to real life, too.
So I think that that's pretty interesting.
There's also cool interactions
that occur on other sites,
but this is very real, I feel,
and I think that's what
we're going for with it.
- Do you think there's anything about you,
like a personal quality of yours
besides basic smartness and determination,
that made you well suited
to work on this project?
I realize this requires
some introspection.
- Yeah.
I actually think determination
is probably the biggest piece.
So many things go wrong when
you're starting a company,
and often, I think people ask,
"What mistakes should you avoid making?"
My answer to that question
is don't even bother
trying to avoid mistakes,
because you're going to
make tons of mistakes.
The important thing is
actually learning quickly
from whatever mistakes you
make and not giving up.
There are things every single
year of Facebook's existence
that could've killed us or made it so that
it just seemed like moving forward
and making a lot of progress
just seemed intractable,
but you just bounce back and you learn.
Nothing is impossible.
You just have to keep
running through the walls.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know, what
did you learn from Mark
that you can immediately apply
to your life or business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Katie Kruse.
Katie, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and making that awesome
animated YouTube summary
of it on your channel.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you for your support.
- [Narrator] We are talking
about Your One Word,
the powerful secret to creating
a business and life that
matters by Evan Carmichael.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(loud whoosh)